Traductor: Max Tremp
Revisor: TED Translators admin
Hay quienes dicen
que somos como cangrejos.
Que cuando alguien quiere salir del barril
te jalan hacia abajo.
Y esto se repite
hasta que ya nadie se quiere mover.
Yo creo que las personas
se parecen más a los elefantes.
Cuando un elefante
está cruzando el camino,
los demás elefantes se ponen atrás
y lo empujan para ayudarlo a salir.
Y es que el mundo no es como un barril
de cangrejos que está estático.
El mundo se está
transformando continuamente,
y hoy se está transformando
en un mundo digital.
Hoy desde un celular puedes comprar,
leer un libro, pedir un taxi,
pagar en la tienda, rentar una casa
y, mi favorita, por una suscripción,
puedes tener toda la música
que te puedas imaginar,
y llevarla a donde tú quieras.
Esa es la transformación digital,
y la mayoría de estas empresas
crecieron y nacieron digitales,
pero hoy, más empresas tradicionales
están intentando hacer
el cambio al mundo digital.
En el 2015, se publicó un estudio
llamado "El vórtice digital".
Vórtice porque se comporta
como un remolino,
donde las empresas
se enfrentan a disrupciones
en sus distintas industrias.
Es un poco caótico, de repente chocan
entre sí y se acelera con el tiempo.
Y una de las conclusiones
de este estudio dice
que 4 de cada 10 empresas dominantes
van a desaparecer en tres años,
es decir, ya.
La otra es que aunque la mitad de la gente
se está dando cuenta del riesgo,
solo una tercera parte
está tomando acción con ellas.
No como los taxistas mexicanos,
que jamás se imaginaron que en 4 años
iba a llegar Uber a competirles.
Y su mentalidad de cangrejo
los hizo rechazar la amenaza,
hacer propaganda negativa.
El día que fueron a bloquear
las calles para protestar,
mi sitio de taxis favorito decidió
bloquear mi lugar de trabajo.
Ese día me convertí en usuario de Uber.
La mentalidad de cangrejo consiguió
el resultado opuesto al que buscaban.
Y es que empresas, gobiernos
y países tienen que entender
que no son una burbuja en el mundo.
Son jugadores globales,
nos guste o no nos guste.
La transformación digital
llegó para quedarse,
así como la revolución industrial.
Y tenemos algunos retos,
para lograr esta transformación.
La primera es la tecnología.
Como este martillo.
Una tecnología que permite
transformar la energía de mi cuerpo,
concentrarla en un punto,
como es un clavo,
y lograr que penetre una superficie
dura como la pared.
Realmente es una tecnología increíble.
Pero la tecnología es
solamente una herramienta.
La podemos utilizar
para lo que fue diseñada,
podemos tratar de vernos creativos
y hacer algo de arte con ella,
o podemos ser destructivos,
(Crac)
y crear un caos pensando
que vamos a sacar valor capital
y solamente creamos destrucción.
Pero la culpa no fue de la tecnología.
No fue del martillo.
Otro ejemplo un poco más reciente:
la inteligencia artificial,
creada en los 50.
Tanto empresas como academia,
por muchos años, por décadas,
trabajaron en tener aplicaciones útiles.
Cuando se lograron, otras empresas
las usaron para mejorar su productividad.
Pero fue ahí donde empezó
la preocupación de la pérdida de empleos,
y ahí entra la sociedad civil, las ONGs,
que meten presión y proponen soluciones
para que tanto empresas como gobiernos
reeduquen a la gente impactada,
para que su situación inclusive mejore
con trabajos de más responsabilidad
y mejor remunerados.
Nuestro siguiente gran reto es el talento,
gente capacitada.
Hace 20 años se formó la academia
de redes "Networking Academy"
que, en sociedad con distintas
universidades alrededor del mundo,
hoy tiene más de un millón
setecientos mil estudiantes.
Pero esto no es suficiente.
En este estudio de IDC,
que intenta medir cuál es la brecha
de conocimiento en redes en Latinoamérica,
nos dice que todavía tenemos
un hueco de una tercera parte.
Es decir, uno de cada tres empleos
en tecnología no se puede llenar
por falta de gente,
y la industria no está cerrando la brecha
ni con inteligencia artificial
ni con tecnologías de "Cloud".
Nosotros damos pláticas
a los alumnos de la academia
para compartir con ellos
tendencias de tecnología,
darles consejos de carrera
y para recomendarles que estudien inglés,
porque un ingeniero sin inglés
es como tratar de abrocharse
un zapato con una sola mano:
no es imposible,
pero es mucho más difícil
y mucho más lento.
Les contamos historias que los inspiren
como el Dr. García Luna,
un mexicano con más de 60 patentes
que han transformado las redes
de computadoras de todo el mundo.
Hacemos eventos enfocados en mujeres
simplemente porque si queremos
resolver un problema
sería muy estúpido hacerlo
con la mitad de los recursos disponibles.
Necesitamos hombres y mujeres por igual.
Como lo hizo Einstein.
Cuando él quería probar
su teoría general de la relatividad,
tenía algunos retos con las matemáticas.
Fue a pedir ayuda
a la universidad de Göttingen
y fue la doctora Emmy Noether
la que le solucionó el problema.
Todo esto suena muy bien,
pero hay veces que dudas.
Dudas que estés haciendo una diferencia
que estés haciendo
un impacto con estas cosas.
Hace algunos años
fui a dar una plática a una universidad,
y antes de empezar
le pregunté a la audiencia
quiénes habían ido
el año anterior a la plática
y quiénes habían aceptado mi reto
de empezar a estudiar inglés.
Nadie levantó la mano; nadie.
Salgo de la plática y, en el pasillo,
había estudiantes más interesados
en el fútbol de las pantallas
que en entrar a aprender
algo nuevo y superarse.
Salí muy triste y decepcionado.
Afortunadamente, tiempo después
me presentaron a un exalumno
que estaba platicando su historia.
Él mencionó que después
de una de estas pláticas
salió inspirado,
decidido a mejorar en sus estudios,
que iban un poco mal.
Decidió certificarse y tratar de trabajar
con nosotros, y lo logró.
En su charla menciona
que esa plática cambió su vida,
y ese comentario a mí me dio la fortaleza
para nunca más volver a cuestionar
el valor que tiene dedicarle tiempo
a la educación y a la juventud.
El siguiente reto
es un poco mas difícil,
es lograr que todo un país
se transforme a una economía digital.
En conjunto con Gartner,
se desarrolló este índice
que intenta medir
qué tan listo está un país
para transformar su economía
en una economía digital.
Ya hablamos de la tecnología
y del capital humano,
y hablamos un poco de la necesidad
de gobiernos y empresarios que inviertan
en esta transformación digital.
Y quedan otras dos métricas
muy interesantes.
Una, la facilidad de hacer negocio
respetando la ley.
Es decir, respetar
la propiedad intelectual,
y estar en un mercado
donde se pueda competir justamente.
La otra son las necesidades
humanas básicas,
porque también vieron hoy
que una persona
con conectividad a Internet
tiene acceso a muchas herramientas
que le pueden transformar
la vida por completo.
Pero si esa persona tiene hambre,
no tiene donde dormir,
no va a poder extraer valor
a esa tecnología.
Este mapa muestra en tres grandes etapas
cómo se encuentran
los distintos países en su evolución.
Los países desarrollados
se encuentran en una etapa
de amplificar lo que vienen haciendo.
La mayoría de nuestros
países latinoamericanos
se encuentran en una etapa intermedia,
que es una etapa de acelerar
esfuerzos que venimos haciendo.
México se encuentra
no en una muy buena posición;
tenemos mucho por hacer
tenemos varios países delante de nosotros:
Uruguay, Chile, Colombia,
Costa Rica, Panamá.
Yo estoy convencido
de que todos podemos ser
solucionadores de problemas globales
si pensamos globalmente
pero ejecutamos localmente,
haciendo un efecto multiplicador.
Hace algunos años,
el gobierno de mi ciudad
decidió cambiar el uso de suelo
de una zona protegida,
unas barrancas que aportan casi el 70 %
del agua potable de la ciudad.
Yo fui a la junta de vecinos
básicamente porque mi esposa me mandó,
es decir, mucha opción no tenía.
(Risas)
Y fui molesto,
fui con un sentimiento de impotencia,
de que iba a perder mi tiempo
y no iba lograr absolutamente nada.
Y grande fue mi sorpresa
que, bien organizados,
logramos revertir esa decisión.
Y fue esa pequeña gran victoria
que me hizo pensar cuando vi este anuncio
de "Mexicanos contra la corrupción",
"Ven a escucharnos",
fui a la plática y salí comprometido
a darles un pequeño donativo mensual.
Y a través de los meses,
viendo los resultados
de sus investigaciones
y publicaciones con la prensa libre
me sentí orgulloso,
orgulloso de haber dado
un granito de arena
para combatir ese gran mal.
Y muy emocionado me fui
con mi equipo de trabajo
a platicarles todas estas historias,
y los invité a meterse
a "Transparencia Internacional"
y firmar la declaración
contra la corrupción.
Después de tres horas
había conseguido 65 personas.
Y eso me puso ha reflexionar.
Yo había pasado la mayor parte
de mi carrera enfocado en mi trabajo,
en el negocio,
y esporádicamente ayudaba a la academia,
pero había dos grandes áreas
donde yo no estaba trabajando en mi vida:
una como ciudadano,
comunicándome con el gobierno,
como peso y contrapeso,
y la otra como parte de la sociedad civil,
tomando parte de mi responsabilidad
en la responsabilidad social.
A este modelo le hacemos falta
cada uno de nosotros,
como una estrella en el centro,
porque cada individuo es una estrella
que puede dar luz a la sociedad.
Y como si se alinearan las estrellas,
al poco tiempo me invitaron a participar
en la fundación de la empresa,
y me pasó como cuando ves
el mar por primera vez:
te sorprendes de la inmensidad del océano.
Me encontré un mundo de ONGs enorme,
enfocadas en salud, en educación,
en combatir el hambre,
en dar apoyo económico,
en transformar al mundo.
Y me acordé de este dicho que dice:
"Camina tan lejos como alcances a ver
y, cuando llegues allá,
vas a poder ver mucho más lejos".
Como la película mexicana
"Nosotros los nobles",
donde Javi, el niño rico
trata de convencer a su papá
de poner gasolineras a domicilio
y todo México se botó de la risa.
Pero cuidado, que esa es nuestra
mentalidad de cangrejo en acción.
Hoy hay más de media docena
de estas empresas en EE.UU.
dando el servicio a precios competitivos
con menos contaminación
y cambiándole la vida
a muchos de sus usuarios.
Eso es ver mas allá.
Y yo vengo aquí ahora
a convencerlos de que Uds. también
pueden ayudar a lograr este cambio.
Pueden empezar con algo
muy sencillo para trascender,
como hacer el juramento
en "Multiply Diversity"
para promover equipos y talento diversos.
Super Rox es uno de los talentos
que me he comprometido a promover
por su maravilloso trabajo.
Y Uds. también pueden hacer la diferencia
para alguien más.
Si ya van calentado motores,
la iniciativa “Global Problem Solvers”,
son unas caricaturas
que están en español también
de un grupo de chavos
con habilidades digitales
y viene acompañado,
en el sitio web “GPS the series”,
de una serie de guías que puedes bajar
para profesores y para padres.
Lo puedes llevar a tu escuela secundaria
a una escuela rural...
Véanlos; pueden usar
de conejillos de Indias
a sus vecinos, a sus primos,
y Uds., aunque no sean ingenieros,
pueden ayudar a disminuir
esta brecha de talento que tenemos.
Y todos podemos [solucionar]
los grandes problemas del mundo.
Todas estas ONGs
combaten la corrupción
de una forma o de otra.
Entren a sus páginas web,
vean de qué se trata,
qué hacen, en qué se pueden involucrar.
Visiten Transparencia Internacional
y busquen la declaración
contra la corrupción.
Inviten a alguien más que la firme.
O estas otras ONGs que combaten el hambre.
Tienen programas con escuelas
porque recuerden:
una persona con hambre
no puede extraer valor
ni a la tecnología ni al conocimiento.
¿Quién de Uds. no ha le regalado
un café a un amigo?
Por el precio de un café al mes,
pueden hacer una donación
que ayude a cambiar el mundo y al país,
y sentirse orgullosos de que están
dando su granito de arena.
Y si todavía no llego a convencerlos
y están pensando "¿Por qué dar
mi tiempo y mi dinero?",
les voy a dar dos razones.
La primera es porque así
Uds. pueden ayudar
a transformar a México
en una económica digital
más prospera y justa para todos,
atacando con estas tres acciones:
el índice de talento,
la facilidad de hacer negocios
combatiendo a la corrupción,
y hacer un país más justo
con las necesidades humanas básicas.
La segunda, cuando Uds.
dan un poquito a los demás
se les regresa de formas inimaginables.
Por ejemplo, a mí me dieron un premio
de una asociación que no conocía: HITEC.
Y tienen un lema: “Push up, pull up”,
"Empuja hacia arriba y jala a los demás".
El lema me encantó.
Es un grupo de ejecutivos
en tecnologías de información
latinos en EE.UU.
que encontraron qué hay en común
en nuestras culturas latinas
para apoyarse mutuamente.
Una verdadera mentalidad de elefante.
Cuando estaba reflexionando
para mi discurso de agradecimiento,
pensando en todas esas personas
que me habían ayudado en el camino,
me habían dado una oportunidad,
incluyendo a quien me había nominado,
me puse a pensar,
y como pueden ver hay
más mujeres que hombres,
y es que la diversidad retribuye.
Es más fácil que una mujer
se tome el tiempo
de rellenar una nominación
para que tú te lleves un premio
a que lo haga un hombre.
Nosotros somos un poquito más flojos.
(Risas)
Pero todos ellos son
parte de mi constelación,
le dan luz a mi vida
y me iluminan el camino.
Espero haberles dado un poco de mi luz,
y los invito a que se conviertan
en una constelación más de México.
Porque recuerden:
las estrellas son fugaces,
pero las constelaciones
son inquebrantables.
Las constelaciones son para siempre.
Muchas Gracias.
(Aplausos)